[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 et cause 7,8 échos dédié
ce soir aux states coast et invest
c'est une plateforme de crowdfunding
fait par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
elle doit permettre de financer des
projets d'entreprises
alors quelles sont les forces du scan
veste sommaire nous avons interviewé
olivier boulay le président de kiosque
sous une veste situé à caen et la
contribuer au projet de la plateforme de
crowdfunding saint-quentinoise focus
aussi sur le podium parc d'elancourt
nous verrons lors de ce reportage
pourquoi le financement est un point
important pour l'évolution d'une
entreprise
et puis nous rencontrerons y foucher
président d'initiatives saint quentin en
yvelines
il est à l'origine du projet si vous
êtes entrepreneur et que vous souhaitez
être sur la plate forme voici ce qu'il
faut savoir tout d'abord l'entreprise
doit être immatriculé être sous la forme
juridique et ça ou sas elle doit déjà
avoir réalisé un premier chiffre
d'affaires
avoir un véritable besoin de financement
entre 100000 et 5 millions d'euros et il
faut savoir que le processus de
développement se fait en cinq étapes
le crowdfunding et un nouveau process en
france d'autres avancent en comptant non
expérimentés comme qu'est-ce que tout
invest à caen et qui collabore aussi
avec skype invest alors nous avons
rencontré pierre boulet voici
l'interview
bon si on veut ce boulet dites moi
pourquoi avoir contribué au ska invest
je crois que le financement est le
maître mot de l'entreprise et que ce cas
invest qui se marie avec coeur ce que
tout une veste c'était une belle
perspective pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui que chacun sait qu'il ya de
grands besoins
l'investissement le sens de l'entreprise
sont des choses qui se se développe de
plus en plus et parallèlement il ya
beaucoup d' épargne dans notre pays
et si les plates formes de participation
financière se développe c'est que il ya
un véritable besoin de réunir le besoin
avec l'offre vous parliez de besoin vous
là c'est vraiment l'agglomération de
saint quentin qui a mis sera en place
avec des partenaires donc vous avez
senti cette demande
c'est à dire que la demande elle est que
ressentie au plan national
lorsque tout une veste est l'émanation a
été créé par une chambre de commerce et
d'industrie celle de caen en normandie
et à ce titre elle est la première dans
son domaine et que
la proximité avec les chambres de
commerce et les différents organismes
qui s'occupent de du développement de
l'entreprise de l'initiative
d'entreprendre nous a forcément conduit
qu'à se rencontrer avec avec 50 et en
yvelines et que ce cas une veste et
dites moi
alors pour ce qui ce k invest
c'est pô juste le territoire où au plan
national alors ce cas je crois pour
vocation de privilégier tous les
dossiers qui vont
qui vont donner du rayonnement et de
l'attractivité au territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines lorsque tout une
veste en revanche a pour vocation d'être
ouvert au travers du réseau de chambre
de commerce est ouvert à tout le
territoire
et vous qui connaissez bien le sujet du
crowdfunding je dis bien oui oui une
participation par la folle de jeu
peut-être utilisé celui ci c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne bien aujourd'hui en
france où c'est peu connu ça démarre ça
démarre on peut pas dire que ça soit
encore suffisamment connue c'est un
grand succès aux états unis et on estime
aujourd'hui que les conditions sont
remplies pour faire en sorte que ça
réussisse aujourd'hui parce qu'encore
une fois comme je vous le disais au
début il ya beaucoup de projets il ya
beaucoup d' épargne donc s'il ya des
outils qui permettent de relier l'un et
l'autre ça doit réussir aujourd'hui on
dit souvent que les sociétés ont du mal
à elle est enfin avoir leur crédit
acceptées par les banques
ça serait la meilleure alternative
aujourd'hui la sonel une leçon par la
foudre c'en est une je ne sais pas si
c'est la meilleure défense en est une
qui est tout à fait pertinente parce que
elle combine l'utilisation de son
épargne
elle développe son territoire et elle
permet à titre personnel de s'investir
dans l'entreprise même si on est salarié
retraité étudiant
c'est une sorte de on s'identifie on
s'identifie à l'entreprise alors j'ai pu
voir que l'agglomération vraiment porté
ce projet c'est pas le cas pour toutes
les plateformes de crowdfunding c'est ça
apporte quelque chose en plus quand des
élus sont derrière porte un projet trano
on est très heureux de ce de ce premier
contrat car c'est un levier fantastique
pour ce que
le rayonnement d'une grande ville une
grande communauté comme saint quentin en
yvelines va contribuer au développement
de l'idée je pense que si tout le monde
apporte sa contribution à la fois le
particulier l'entreprise et les projets
à financer
je pense qu'on est de là on démarre une
grande une grande étape du financement
donc les élus derrière skate ou sky
invest comme vous avez entendu ça vous
ai dit on y va avant qu on y va tous les
chefs d'entreprise qu'ils soient jeunes
ou moins jeunes sont tout à fait emballé
par ce projet eh bien merci monsieur
goulet merci à vous et vous avez pu le
comprendre lors de l'interview le
financement d'une entreprise est un
enjeu capital à son développement
focus sur le haut john parkes
d'elancourt qui sans financement
n'aurait jamais vu le jour
c'est suite à un voyage aux etats unis
que christophe petits découvrent le john
parkes tout de suite il a l'idée d'en
faire un en france pour financer son
plan il fait le tour des banques mais
aucune d'elles ne donne du crédit à son
projet il décide donc de le présenter à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
le principe est donc on vient présenter
son dossier devant un jury donc un
passage tous les mois et un jury qui se
réunit et donc on passe un par un les
candidats où on expose son dossier on a
fait un petit dossier un dossier sur
excel ont présenté aux membres du jury
et une dizaine de personnes composé de
deux banquiers d'experts comptables de
personnes de personnes de la société
civile privée comme des entrepreneurs
des choses comme ça il obtient après de
l'agglomération en juin 2016 avec son
appui il obtient aussi plus rapidement
un crédit des banques ce qui lui permet
d'accélérer la création du john parkes
six mois après ouverture du john parkes
le pari est réussi pour christophe petit
l'indifférence vous verrez c'est ni plus
ni moins que voilà une structure qui
accueille
des gens de tout âge de tout horizon des
petits des grands familles on a mis des
enterrements de vie de garçon de jeune
fille aulas va lancer quelque chose de
très vastes et c'est un projet auquel je
suis très content et que apparemment les
gens aussi donc c'est plutôt chouette
selon christophe petit le haut john
parkes remporté un franc succès pour le
moment
il collabore avec les maisons de
quartiers de l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise vous avez pu voir que
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines aide vraiment les entreprises à
se développer
faisons maintenant un point avec le
président d'initiatives saint quentin en
yvelines et fouché bonjour monsieur
bonsoir c'est vrai alors ce projet et
sky une veste
ça vous tient à coeur j'ai l'impression
pourquoi parce que d'abord je suis
entrepreneur dans l'âme et que j'aime ce
territoire et les entreprises du
territoire les habitants du territoire
et que tout ce que l'on peut faire pour
faciliter la croissance des entreprises
b il faut essayer de le faire
on avait déjà des outils il en manquait
encore on a trouvé et mis en place ces
petites financement participatif
c'est vrai que j'en suis assez heureux
c'est une demande des entreprises j'ai
l'impression que le crowdfunding en
france encore à son balbutiement
le crowdfunding le financement
participatif en étant c'est vrai le
financement participatif évidemment si à
peu près 200 millions d'euros quand il
ya 900 milliards d'euros d'encours de
financement burger donc on a encore de
la marge de progression mais il ya un
vrai engouement pour ce dispositif et en
plus ça présente l'avantagé de donner
une réalité territoriale en fait bon et
pas sûr que les investisseurs viennent
que de saint quentin et j'espère même
qui viendront de très loin on va pas
dépasser qu'est-ce qui se battent banc
mais oui soyons modèle qu'areva déjà
démarré dès ce soir mais mais mais dès
ce soir j'ai constaté qu'il y avait
un certain engouement dans donc il ya
une réalité territoriale des entreprises
de saint quentin des habitants de saint
quentin des avancées des investisseurs
saint quentinois
je pense que ça peut marcher à 50 ça va
être un outil en plus pour les
entrepreneurs du web et parce que
aujourd'hui on avait on a un outil qui
est la plateforme initiative saint
quentin qui consentent des prêts
d'honneur a dit l'entrepreneur soit qui
démarre sottise développe soit qui
veulent reprendre une entreprise
mais notre financement est limitée par
rapport à l'organisation même à au
maximum une centaine de milliers d'euros
donc au dessus de 100 mille euros on
n'avait pas d'outils disponibles
bien sûr il ya les banques mais on
n'avait pas d'outil local disponible
donc on a cherché et en fait aujourd'hui
avec cette plateforme de financement
participatif soit sous forme de prêt
soit sous forme de participation au
capital
on peut aller de 100 mille euros jusqu'à
un million d'euros
peut être plus alors pour rassurer un
petit peu des personnes qu'ils
participeraient enfin qui donnerait un
petit peu alors leur argent pour aider
ces entreprises
est-ce qu'ils sont sûrs de retrouver
leurs sous derrière ou est-ce qu'il peut
même le doublé alors ils peuvent le
doublé voilà est en tout cas si c'est un
prêt ils doubleront pas et ils auront
une rémunération d'un prêt comme on peut
avoir des réalisations qui aujourd'hui
sont dérisoires d'ailleurs mais là il y
aura un taux d'intérêt assez
significatif d'accord si c'est des
participations alors là ils peuvent
doubler tripler quadrupler son tu crées
si on trouve le futur google à saint
quentin en yvelines
on peut être optimiste mais met en
revanche en revanche il faut être
complètement honnête et transparent c
du financement participatif avec un
risque complète vient pas de garanties
mais on s'est un prêt le risque est
moindre parce que quand même il ya une
équipe qui fait l'audit de l'entreprise
qui cherche un prêt donc et après ça se
rembourse donc ne vont pas capoter dès
le lendemain matin
si c'est un investissement capital nul
ne peut dire si l'entreprise va se
développer
devenir google enfin gaf a oui si
malheureusement le projet n'aboutit pas
et auquel cas donc il ya un vrai risque
qu'il faut pas se tromper d'ennemi et
menthe
quel type d'entreprise on peut trouver
sur 7
plateforme quel type de l'entreprise on
va trouver sur cette plateforme
et aussi comment elles sont choisies
parce que à la porte qui ne pas
débarquer comme savidan est d'abord et
c'est d'une plateforme qui est ouverte à
des entreprises existantes mac donc ce
ne sont pas des porteurs de projets ok
déjà ensuite en revanche c'est tout type
d'entreprise 50 interdit novation mais
l'innovation dans l'esprit généralement
admise c'est l'innovation technologique
mais pas que vous pouvez être innovant
dans le commerce où pourrait-il devant
dans le service vous pouvez et innovants
dans tous les domaines donc la
plateforme elle est ouverte à tous les
types d'activités simplement le dossier
sera présenté à un comité d'audit et on
fera ce qu'on appelle des diots
diligence dans le jardin dans le jargon
c'est à dire qu'on va regarder si ce qui
est expliqué vrai sans perspectives sont
réalistes et
donc non il faudra quand même
sérieusement présenter patte blanche
avant de pouvoir être financés donc être
mère et pour finir qu'est-ce que vous
souhaiter à cette plateforme
saint-quentinoise jeu pour finir je
souhaite que tout simplement là on vient
de finir l'inauguration j'ai déjà trois
personnes qui sont venues me voir en me
disant j'ai sûrement deux projets avoue
présence à bord de mer c'est plutôt
satisfaisant donc ce que je souhaite
c'est que on est un nombre significatif
de projets dans l'année qui vient 2017
si on pouvait en avoir 10 12 à financer
parce que l'important c'est d'avoir des
entreprises à financer
je pense que des investisseurs ce sera
relativement puissant donc j'espère pour
la plateforme est pour ça qu en tournée
mais qu'on retrouve une dizaine
d'entreprises à financer dès l'année
prochaine et pourquoi pas le nouveau
google et pourquoi pas le nouveau google
puisque dans ce cas youtube il ya
peut-être le google de demain
on croise les doigts merci à vous c'est
la fin de ce set 8 échos bonne soirée à
tous et surtout bonne fête
[Musique]